through our local covert alert levels
we've been able to take a balanced
approach
and today i'd like to update the house
on some further changes
that we're making unfortunately we're
seeing rising rates of infection in
stoke-on-trent
in coventry and in slough in all of
these areas there are over 100 positive
cases per hundred thousand people
cases are doubling around every
fortnight and we're seeing a concerning
increase of cases among the over 60s
so we've agreed in partnership with
local leaders to move these areas
into the high local alert level coming
into force
at one minute past midnight on saturday
the central change is that people cannot
now
meet other households socially indoors
this applies in any setting at home or
in a restaurant or any other venue
the rule of six still applies to any
outdoor setting
and although you may continue to travel
to open venues
you should reduce the number of journeys
where possible
i'd like to thank local leaders in these
areas for the work that they've done
for their corporation and i can assure
the people of stoke-on-trent
of coventry and of slough that will
support you
all the way through including with the
business support that the chancellor
announced earlier today for all areas
with a high
local alert level